j'en suis très contente parce que je
cherche du travail depuis tellement
longtemps et ça paraît correspondre à ce
que je peux faire monter à bord d'un de
ses bus pour découvrir le métier de
conducteur c'est ce qu'a proposé le
groupe savak à une dizaine de demandeurs
d'emploi ce mardi 19 avril je suis ravi
de pouvoir avoir cette opportunité
ouverte parce que le métier que je
faisais
il est mort en quelque sorte tout ce que
je sais faire les pires connu faut bien
que je bondis moi ça me remet dans le
bain puis ça me permet de voir comment
la société pendant les systèmes
fonctionnent actuellement au programme
de la matinée une réunion de
présentation de la société et de ses
métiers suivie d'une découverte de
lignes régulières entre la verrière et
saint rémy les chevreuse on réalise dans
le cadre des recrutements des stages de
ce type là alors plutôt sur des heures
de pointe là c'était vraiment pour avoir
une première approche pour que les gens
puissent se projeter sur que fait un
conducteur de car quand il est en phase
de conduite comment ça se passe avec ses
clients après avoir déjeuné ensemble
après midi est consacré à de nouvelles
discussions et des entretiens
individuels l'occasion d'aborder les
métiers possibles entre tourisme lignes
régulières transport d'entreprise aux
scolaires mais aussi les contraintes il
faut bien sûr se lever tôt le matin
puisque nous emmenons soit les
personnels soient les enfants à l'école
ou au travail donc vous comprenez bien
qu'on démarre leur journée avant eux et
le soir on finit aussi après eux
puisqu'on y ramène de l'emploi vers leur
domicile le groupe sovac recherche une
centaine de conducteurs pour
reconstituer les effectifs d'avant
qu'ovide et amorcer convenablement la
période de tourisme estival